Next, we're going to demonstrate
an example of multiple linear aggression
with the data set that includes
the average number of tickets,
the number of employees, and
the value of the contract.
For this example,
we're going to use Microsoft Excel.
You can perform multiple linear
aggression in Google Sheets with
the Linest function but
Excel provides a richer output.
Note that to perform this next step you
need to have the Analysis Tool Pack
add-in active in Microsoft Excel.
To start the analysis go to the Data
menu and select Data Analysis.
Highlight Regression and click OK.
The input y-range should be
the range of your target variable.
In this case,
the average number of tickets.
The input x-range should be the range
of data of your predictor variables,
in this case, the number of employees
and the value of the contract.
Clicking OK will run the model and
provide an output.
We can quickly see our coefficients
of our linear equation
which results in an equation
of y = -24.2667 +
0.1019 x1 + 0.00067 x2,
where x1 is the number of employees and
x2 is the value of the contract.